[Music]
really kind of actually said like at
least stuttering john oh by the way you
know we didn't get to stuttering john
yet
his [ __ ] cancer scam i sent you oh
[ __ ] no you're right yes i actually have
it yeah i have to have it i sent that to
you uh sunday because it's yeah yep yep
um yep i actually had it in the
prep thing right
here let me make sure this is the right
one you're talking about
the
hold on i'm not afraid to sue that one
well the before that or the one before
that time stamp the one before it
which is what started the whole thing
and by the way i watched two of these
podcasts cover this a little bit and
uh they were covering anthony covering
it so it was like inception but i gotta
give uh erock
because he was he was he was uh at
anthony's show obviously because he's
the producer and like you know they went
to the [ __ ] producer thing and
they're like he rock what do you think
of this rock's like this is extremely
illegal
you know you rock always just dead
pissed yeah yeah yeah it was just this
is extremely illegal
[Laughter]
oh yeah get ready this is fun okay so
this one that you time stamped at 239
now the stuttering this one right
correct i got it queued up so you don't
have to watch the stupid usa singers
here we go well hello everybody welcome
to the stuttering john podcast with your
favorite host stuttering john melendez
uh
uh okay let me just address this
one of our beloved
chatters
loved one is going through expensive ass
chemo
they have chosen to remain anonymous
any paypal
donation will go to help
pay for the chemo
so anything that you send to me
through paypal
i promise will go
directly
to that person
oh can i say something really quick
you please
[Laughter]
i know there's so many questions can i
this is
this is extremely illegal it's very
illegal
um is he
buddy first off i think obviously i
think he's lying but let's say it's true
i like to play before i even continue
let's say it's true he's been waiting
for trump to go to jail for a year how
great would it be if he goes to jail
before trump does the person starts to
go fund me that way you're not liable
for any of this if people send you
paypal money and then you give it away
you have now the tax burden on that
that's how that works
you also have to explain and show your
receipts and it's ever nobody's going to
trust you no matter how much you [ __ ]
prove that john
there's there's there's two ways to do
this and you're going to mix the money
with other money from other
there's two ways
to give to charity on a stream
one
like royce said and we've done this a
million times
[ __ ] going through [ __ ] we you know will
go hey you know like let's help them out
you know they're trying to raise some
money they had some setbacks whatever um
or the other way and i've done this and
i'm sure royce has done these before
when you do like a stream like you'll
say like all right this week like i'm
gonna give 25 of all my donors yeah i've
done that but like toys for tots yeah
i've done that that's easy peasy because
it's a tax write-off anyway so you're
not taking a burden and you're also
getting like
it's very easy to just i've done it you
just screenshot the [ __ ] receipt and
go oh yeah because guys i gave money to
toys for tots you know what i mean but
like this is a random person we don't
know who it is so there's no
accountability that the money is going
to to pro to the person that you think
is and by the way is he thinking by the
way in karma phase in the sat says and
also 10 goes to the big guy
you got to kick it up to the big guy
what is he doing
uh
john
crimes i think i have done everything
that i can do and
have you started a gofundme
because that's like something you could
do by the way you can even do the
gofundme for them and then you then the
way the process works is they reach out
to the person that it's for and confirm
and then the money will go directly to
them you could even yeah you could even
set up a gofundme for somebody and tell
gofundme
i want nothing to do with this cash all
this money goes to this person
this is just something else that i can
do
so if you want to help
fine if you can't afford to
fine
maybe one day
i'll be able to tell you who it is
but right now
they have chosen
for me not to reveal
who they are
but it's someone that we all
know and love
howard stern has cancer
and is in this chat on a regular basis
oh no
do you think carl from [ __ ] all these
podcasts has cancer because he's in that
chat on a regular basis
what if it's just coral scamming
so uh i would never ask
if it wasn't
something important
all right
now
that that is said let me just fix my
green screen
settings here i think that should be
good
hey virgie
um
do you think his green screen settings
look good
i i didn't even know he had a green
screen until you told me oh you thought
he was in the big city
yeah i thought he was i thought he was
just you know balling
he has to steal he has to steal his
internet from his mexican neighbor
everything john does
what does his mexican neighbors have
ispector
come on man that's not nice okay they
have affinity
[Laughter]
they have whatever the government gives
mexicans that move to l.a
they have that internet service
and now we get on with the show
so
happy days are here again this time
oh my god i just noticed a shirt
i just noticed a shirt
it's a shirt it's a shirt i'm sorry it's
a shirt with it's a shirt with
it's a shirt with cavanaugh on it it's
and it says oh my god and i bet you the
bottom says [ __ ]
or traits or rapists or traitors
it's pretty cool oh
i hate him oh i hate him
oh he's so stupid
happy days are here again
and how did this not push nikki free to
win
i know you'd think she would this would
have put her right over the top how did
this not just
rocket her to the top
yeah so that's his um now he's now he's
mad and he's threatening to sue
everybody and now okay so i think he's
panicking you sent me two other clips
are they related the shorter one i think
is is really good and then the other
one's more of like the floor okay so
thank you so this is 123 this is the
clip okay here we go real quick show
links
okay
see show links
supreme liars the shirt says supreme
liars
ah okay you nailed them john you got him
democrat because i'm not i can't tell
because it's tits but the shirt come up
you know john tits the thing you have
but your son no longer does
pocketing
this money [ __ ] [ __ ] him bro he [ __ ]
tried to sue us he could suck
no he didn't no he didn't try to sue us
he wrote us a dm
and we we told him to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
remember how hard our lawyer left when
we sent it to him and he was like i was
like we were like what do we do with the
video he's like keep it up here he goes
he sent a cease and desist via twitter
and he's like yeah he goes did you send
you a document i'm like no he's like
he's not
making they're not gonna do anything
i think remember he told us it's the
first time that anyone's ever sent this
this is through a twitter tm
sorry chris let's put the clip
that i am pocketing
this money
oh here it is here it is
now
the person who
i have been trying to help knows
that is not the case
in fact another person in this chat
knows
that is not the case then why don't we
just have some transparency
since i then you want let me let me
explain let me just explain something
you want trump to show his tax returns
but you don't want to say who the person
is you're giving the money to
oh i see
the entire amount plus some
that i received
to
a person in this chat
because the person undergoing the chemo
uh spouse they don't use
paypal or venmo enslave
and by the way you know the person
whose spouse is going through chemo
this person said to me
john
i could really use
an ipad
an apple product
so my
love
your [ __ ]
you know what i'm worried about marsh
i'm worried about
that i don't think he's lying about the
money
i think he might be getting worked
because whenever somebody it was for
chemo right
why would you ask like that should who
cares about your wife could watch tv
if it's for chemo all the money should
go to that why for a new not even for a
new ipad or a thousand dollars do you
think somebody's working john i'm wor
i'm thinking that somebody is working
with him he's just full of [ __ ] well i
think that he's stupid you're forgetting
how stupid he is
he's very stupid
he is very stupid but he's also not
genuinely generous
i think that this person probably said
hey uh what if uh you know i my wife has
chemo whatever
i bet if um i bet if you
bring that up you'll get more donors and
then cut me in a little bit for the
chemo or something like that maybe maybe
i just feel like there's still an angle
here
and john i guess you could probably sue
people but then the issue is the
discovery part will come out then you'll
have to say who the who the person is
undergoing the hours of chemo treatment
what did i do
also there's there were some rumors that
the dabbler's anonymous forum that uh
apparently john is selling his condo
according to them and that like he's
looking for a new place
which the timing of this is kind of also
very curious to them well selling in for
closing are two things but yeah i'm with
you
you're like a short sale is not a sale
yeah
can
play games
converse with me uh-huh while he's
undergoing the hours of chemo treatment
okay what did i do
i got one but i thought his loved one
was good
what did i do
i got one
what kind of person does this
what brags about their charity on their
stream get more donors
with my own money
what money
and mailed it to this person
and you know how much i hate going to
the post office yeah plus you don't
expect the postage it's expensive
yeah that's what i did
wow
what a hero what a hero guys
what a hero
what what have you give all them we just
funneled all the money to nikki freeze
campaign that would be even funnier
uh for her to not even win the primary
exactly